les images des fermes inondées et des
bêtes prisonnières des eaux l'année
dernière en Colombie-Britannique ont
marqué beaucoup de gens en particulier
les agriculteurs qui pouvaient très bien
s'identifier à la détresse de leur
collègues un an après la catastrophe ou
en sont aujourd'hui les fermiers de la
prairie sous masse une de nos équipes
est allée à leur rencontre
[Musique]
le train de 10h sur la ferme laitière de
Robert
un matin bien ordinaire tireton
et les apparences sont trompeuses
à l'extérieur de l'étable se trouve un
champ de 4 hectares ou poussant en
normal des cultures qui servent à
nourrir les vaches
ce printemps c'est devenu un lac il y
avait du maïs et une culture de
couverture dans ce champ jusqu'au 16
novembre 2021
ce champ là pourrait ne plus jamais
produire comme avant
[Musique]
de naturelles de l'histoire canadienne
c'est la chose la plus impressionnante
que j'ai vu je ne savais pas quoi dire
j'étais figé et je me demandais ce qui
venait de se passer
l'automne 2021 est arrivé en tronc sur
la côte ouest
alors
une bombe météorologique s'abat sur
l'île de Vancouver 9000 résidences en
panne de courant
deux semaines plus tard une tornade
touche le sol à l'université de la
Colombie Britannique
encore plus dangereux prends des forces
au-dessus du Pacifique une rivière
atmosphérique se dirige vers la côte
américaine
ces rivières dans le ciel ce sont de
larges bandes d'humidité qui s'étendent
sur des centaines de kilomètres des
systèmes souvent inoffensifs qui se
transforme en neige ou en pluie mais
celui-ci est bien pire
20 mm de pluie en une heure c'est assez
normal mais trois ou quatre heures de
pluie comme ça c'est étonnant
le 13 novembre la tempête bifurque vers
la Colombie-Britannique en deux jours
plus de 300 mm de pluie tombe dans
certaines régions des routes et des
ponts sont emportées par les flots et
dans l’intérieur de la province des
glissements terrains coupe tout acceptes
à des communautés entières
mais l'une des régions les plus
vulnérables en Colombie-Britannique
c'est la vallée du fleuve Freezer et la
prairie sous masse du terrain agricole
entouré de montagnes et à la merci des
caprices du freezer l'existence de ces
terres repose sur un réseau de digues et
de stations de pompage qui empêche les
eaux du fleuve de se frayer un chemin
vers la prairie
tôt ce matin nous avons élargi l'ordre
d'évacuation dans la prairie sous masse
1100 résidence sans toucher
la prairie sous masse est menacée par
trois cours d'eau le freezer au nord la
rivière à l'est et la rivière Sumas qui
arrivent des États-Unis avec les pluies
des derniers jours l'eau débordent déjà
au-dessus des digues et le 16 novembre à
14h30 c'est la catastrophe la digue qui
retient la rivière sous masse cède elle
se brise à 150 mètres de l'étable de
Robert piocons
mais vu ce mur d'eau de 3 à 5 mètres de
hauteur s'engouffrer par la brèche dans
la digue
dans mes allées il fallait prendre une
décision rapidement alors on a décidé de
chasser les vaches à l'extérieur j'avais
peur qu'elle soit prise dans les tables
à l'extérieur au moins elle pouvait se
rendre sur les parties en hauteur de mon
terrain
on a embarqué dans le bateau et on a dit
au revoir aux vaches dans ma cour qui
nous regardait c'était sur réel
je pensais qu'elle serait toute morte à
mon retour surtout je me sentais mal
pour les gens qui se trouvaient plus
loin au sud il n'avait aucune idée de ce
qui s'en venait
l'inquiétude et de sa famille deviendra
rapidement celle de tous les producteurs
de la prairie sous-mance
globe fait son chemin vers le sud et les
fermes situées au creux de la vallée
dans celle de Philippe Grimm
le producteur laitier vient d'acheter la
ferme de son père et ses 500 vaches
par précaution Philippe avait déjà
évacué ces 230 vaches laitières
[Musique]
n'importe quel fermier qui avait un
camion et une remarque qui était là pour
transporter nos vaches des gens que je
ne connaissais même pas en me disait un
tel ou un tel a de la place je les
appelais en envoyait quelques vaches
là-bas je n'avais aucune idée où elle
est toute c'était le chaos
le 16 novembre il apprend que la
diversité
30 minutes plus tard l'inimaginable se
produit
j'ai vu une vague de deux pieds arrivés
entre mes étables là-bas et je me suis
dit ça y est je ne savais pas à quoi
m'attendre mais c'était vrai il fallait
agir et vite
on avait de l'eau jusqu'à la taille on
sortait les veaux de cette étape pour
ensuite les aider à nager en haut de la
butte jusqu'à l'autre étable pour les
sortir de l'eau
mais l'eau continue à monter
l'eau elle est jusqu'ici le premier jour
et elle s'est rendue jusque là au cours
des jours suivants et quelques heures
après que la digue CD les animaux ont
les pâtes dans l'eau il fait appel à ses
voisins qui ont des bateaux
on entrait dans les tables avec le
bateau et on embarquait les veaux ça
prenait trois ou quatre gars pour
s'assurer qu'ils ne sautent pas dans
l'eau on arrivait à la route et là on
les montait dans une remarque qui les
amenaient ailleurs
il réussit à sauver ainsi une
soixantaine de veaux
mais il reste 200 torts dans les tables
trop lourdes pour les bateaux
Philippe et sa famille doivent les
abandonner leur maison est inondée
[Musique]
il revient le lendemain avec un
vétérinaire
il y a plus d'un mètre d'eau dans les
tables où se trouve ces deux sont bêtes
[Musique]
le vétérinaire trouvait que les risques
pour la santé des vaches étaient trop
élevé qu'elles auraient des problèmes
plus tard et qu'elle ne survivraient
probablement pas on a donc décidé de les
abattre
une quarantaine de fermes laitières dans
la prairie sous mars sont inondés
[Musique]
plus de 420
de poulaillers sont aussi atteints ainsi
que trois porcheries le bilan est lourd
12000 ports et 600000 poulets morts
les pertes chez les éleveurs s'élèvent à
plusieurs centaines de millions de
dollars
[Musique]
la prairie sous masse produit la moitié
du poulet des produits laitiers et des
œufs consommés en Colombie britanniques
mais la région n'a pas toujours été le
berceau de l'agriculture dans la
province
au début du 20e siècle cette prairie
était en fait le lac sous masse dans les
années 20 un projet ambitieux est lancé
qui changera le paysage et l'économie de
la région
le lac tsumas aider des pompes empêche
l'eau de revenir
qui sortent et professeur d'histoire à
l'université de la vallée
son grand-père a aidé à créer la prairie
sous-masse en tant que travailleur sur
une drague dans les années 20 il était
très fier d'avoir aidé à drainer le lac
c'est un tour de force d'ingénierie
le but du projet créer des terres
agricoles dans une province où il y en
avait très peu
il y avait plusieurs sources d'eau le
but c'était de détourner les cours d'eau
renforcer les berges puis réduire la
taille du lac pour enfin le drainer
complètement
on a ensuite offert ces terres au colon
pour qu'il puisse défricher les terres
et il établir des fermes
la province gagne son Paris les sols
riches de la prairie sous-masse et son
climat tempérés en font l'une des
régions agricoles les plus productives
au pays mais à quel prix
c'est évident que ce lac ne veut pas
disparaître et continue à trouver des
moyens de se manifester
c'est justement ce qui s'est passé à
l'automne 2021
lorsque Robert Buckens revient chez lui
le lendemain de l'inondation de setter
il constate que presque toutes ses
vaches ont survécu l'eau s'est retiré
rapidement
quand la digue l'eau était rendue ici
mais en peu de temps l'eau s'est retiré
parce qu'elle coulait vers les fermes
sur les terrains plus bas
mais l'impact sur ces terres est majeur
là où je me trouve c'est la hauteur
normale de mon terrain près de la digue
cela que 5 mètres de profondeur
[Musique]
il y avait des roches éparpillées
jusqu'à 100 ou 120 mètres
la moitié de ces 30 hectares a été
inondé ce qui réduira de moitié sa
production de mouler en 2022 il a dû
acheter du foin qu'il a payé très cher
l'an dernier une balle de foin me
coûtait 40 dollars aujourd'hui on en
trouve même pas à 100 dollars il y a une
pénurie de nourriture pour animaux dans
les provinces de l'Ouest mais ce qu'il
craint surtout c'est l'impact à long
terme sur ces champs je pense que 10
ocre de mon terrain seront gravement
touchés parce que si on perd la couche
de 15 cm de terre arable on part aussi
la couche d'argile en dessous c'est
irremplaçable la biomasse les vers de
terre tout ça ça disparaît
trois semaines après l'inondation
et sa famille sont revenus à la ferme
le coût est dur 2 millions de dollars de
pertes et de dommages remboursés en
partie seulement par leurs assurances et
l'aide fédérales on ne va jamais être
compensé pour toutes nos pertes ça va
prendre quelques années avant qu'on soit
là où on en était avant
il a commencé à acheter des vaches pour
renouveler son troupeau
un travail de longue haleine
plusieurs d'entre elles étaient
enceintes c'était notre avenir pour les
trois prochaines années on peut les
remplacer par d'autres vaches mais ce
n'est pas la même chose que celle qu'on
élève soi-même
et au-delà des chiffres il y a la plaie
émotionnelle qui risque de prendre
encore plus longtemps à guérir
l'innovation chaque fois que je
traversais une étable je ne voyais
qu'une vingtaine de vaches je me disais
c'est pas normal ça c'est beaucoup trop
calme
[Musique]
en plus de fournir la majorité du poulet
du port et du lait de la Colombie
Britannique la prairie sous masse une
région extrêmement fertile abrite aussi
une variété impressionnante de
production agricoles et les inondations
n'ont épargnées aucune d'entre elles
mai 2022
le calme est de retour dans la prairie
sous masse
[Musique]
sur la ferme de after le son d'un
tracteur brise le silence
scène bucolique et qui marque le début
de nouvelle saison agricoles
mais ces travaux labourous aussi un
sentiment de deuil
[Musique]
c'est très dur mais je dis pas le choix
il ne reste plus rien dans le champ
dans ce champ il avait semé 250 000
bulbes de safran importés de l'Inde
après 6 ans d'essaye d'erreur after
espérer cueillir sa première récolte en
ici je pensais peut-être que la récolte
survivrait mais j'ai vérifié après
l'inondation tout était perdu
son voisin au nord
a enfin le courage aujourd'hui de
nettoyer ce qui reste de sa pépinière
je vous dirai que 10 ou 20% seulement
vont survivre
il a acheté ce terrain en 2019 pour se
lancer dans la culture de cèdre et il a
fait construire avec son épouse une
nouvelle maison sur la propriété
[Musique]
ma première récolte ici sur laquelle
j'ai mis trois à quatre ans de travail
mais le 16 novembre 2021 tout a basculé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
près 3 jours de pluie diluvienne les
rivières soumasses débordent de son lit
pavane
elle s'est mise à crier il y a un lac
d'or
il y avait de l'eau partout c'était
incroyable on pouvait voir la digue au
loin qui cédait on est parti dans le
camion de mon mari quand j'y pense
c'était effrayant
on ne voyait pas la route il y avait des
fossés des deux côtés l'eau commençait à
entrer dans le camion
mes enfants ma femme
on est parti
le jour même la digue finit par céder
en après-midi Lio rejoint les fermes
dans le sud de la prairie soumass où se
trouve l'une des plus importantes
concentration de bleuetière au pays
[Musique]
dont celle de Jack torrent single
je voyais par la fenêtre l'eau qui
arrivait très vite
pas les bijoux de ma femme pas d'argent
rien on est parti avec ce qu'on avait
dans les poches
dans son champ de douze hectares se
retrouvent sous 3 mètres d'eau
quelques jours plus tard Jack torrent
revient en bateau
même pas les poteaux
sans oxygène ces plans peuvent survivre
une journée ou deux mais ils sont restés
sous l'eau 10 ou 12 jours
[Musique]
les voitures étaient sous l'eau
ma pépinière aussi 35 40 000 arbres sous
l'eau
[Musique]
restreint inondée pendant presque 3
semaines l'eau annule par à s'écouler
ces terres agricoles parmi les plus
réchauffés se retrouvent de nouveau au
fond d'un lac disparu depuis 100 ans
c'était troublant une étendue d'eau de
50 km² est apparu soudainement avec ici
et là des bâtiments de ferme
[Musique]
la sécurité alimentaire et
l'environnement
si les images de la prairie inondées
étaient bouleversantes le désastre
n'était pas complètement inattendu pour
autant
cette région agricole extrêmement
fertile qu'on a travaillé si fort à
protéger est aussi le centre névralgique
des voies ferrées et de l'autoroute la
transcanienne
tout se rejoint ici dans ce bassin
donc quand c'est inondé c'est grave les
fermes sont sous l'eau mais aussi tout
ce qui nous relie au reste du pays
les conditions météorologiques à
l'automne 2021 était propice au
déclenchement d'un tel désastre mais ce
n'était pas la première fois que la
prairie sous-main si non des
prête en 1948 20 ans après la création
de la prairie le lac sous mars est
revenu en raison de la fonte rapide de
la neige
selon l'historien kristorcel l'entretien
des digues était laissé à la
responsabilité des fermiers
et c'est eux qui devront aussi affronter
le désastre de l'inondation de 1948
parmi les centaines de fermes inondées
en 1948 se trouvait la ferme de son
grand-père qui avait été aidé à créer la
prairie sous-mance dans les années 20
[Musique]
frappé leur maison si fort qu'elle a été
déplacée de sa fondation
toute leur poule ils ont perdu leur
ferme et ont décidé de quitter leur
terre j'en étais trop
en avril 2022 pavane in the winder
redémarrage enfin chez eux
constate l'ampleur des dommages à sa
pépinière la plupart de ces plus jeunes
arbres sont perdus emportés par l’eau et
déposé dans les champs et les fossés à
des kilomètres à la ronde
ces arbres matures plantés dans le sol
ont survécu en grande partie mais les
arbres intermédiaires toujours dans des
pots sont durement touchés
somme toute il a perdu environ la moitié
de ses 40.7 le gouvernement lui a
remboursé les coûts de son système
d'irrigation environ 15000 dollars mais
rien pour ces arbres une perte de 200000
dollars
le printemps c'est ma grossesse
j'aurais déjà dû livrer 6000 arbres à la
fin avril
ce qui m'aurait fait de belles rentrées
d'argent
mais là je ne sais pas ça va prendre des
années à repousser
et sa famille reviennent chez eux en mai
les rénovations se poursuivent leur
cuisine pour l'instant et dans le garage
mais leur bleu est tiers est une perte
totale
mais c'est parce qu'il restait un peu
d'énergie dans les racines
ils ne pourront pas tolérer la chaleur
parce qu'ils sont malades
sans produits
il doit arracher tous ses 45 000 plans
le coût pour les remplacer sera
remboursé par la province mais il perd
une bonne partie de ses revenus annuels
et les bleuets peuvent prendre jusqu'à 8
ans avant de produire à pleine capacité
c'est très difficile on ne sait pas trop
quoi faire on dirait qu'on est perdu
dans le noir
on ne sait pas comment s'en sortir
près de 150 producteurs de bleuets dans
la prairie sous-masse ont été touchés
par les inondations soit plus de 1000
hectares de bleuets
[Musique]
after a d'ailleurs perdu une partie de
sabléière il sera compensé mais pour sa
production de safran pour laquelle il
avait investi près d'un demi million il
a reçu la date 26000 dollars
pour after comme pour d'autres c'est un
projet de vie qui a sombré dans les eaux
de la rivière sous masse
tout est perdu
je m'en souviens
je ne peux pas vous expliquer
[Musique]
peu d'agriculteurs dans la prairie sous
mars sont sortis indemne de l'inondation
dévastatrice de 2021
[Musique]
des travaux sont déjà en cours pour
renforcer les digues et augmenter la
capacité des stations pompage qui
protègent la région
mais une question demeure ce drame
aurait-il pu être évité
[Musique]
parmi les choses qu'on ne contrôle pas
il y a bien sûr la météo le jour où des
pluies diluviennes s'abattent sur nous
notre marge de manœuvre est bien mince
mais dans le cas de la prairie sous
masse plusieurs personnes avaient tiré
la sonnette d'alarme et ça depuis des
années sauf que les autorités en fait la
sourde oreille
[Musique]
une semaine après l'inondation de la
prairie sous-masse l'ingénieur Thompson
la région
c'est tellement beau et là on regarde en
bas on voit une ferme inondée et on
constate que l'étable a de l'eau
jusqu'aux toit qui sait ce qui se trouve
à l'intérieur c'est horrible
son domaine d'expertise c'est la
protection des communautés à risque
d'inondations et l'étudie le bassin de
la prairie sous-masse depuis une
vingtaine d'années j'écoutais les
prévisions météorologiques et j'ai
ressenti quelque chose dans mon ventre
j'ai pensé est-ce que ce sera le moment
où je pourrais dire je vous l'avais dit
depuis sa création dans les années 1920
la prairie a été inondée à plusieurs
reprises d'abord en 1948 puis au
printemps 1972 lorsque la fonte rapide
de la neige a fait déborder les rivières
au dessus des digues
en 1990 plusieurs maisons ont été
détruites par la crue des eaux provenant
de l'État de Washington au sud
[Musique]
voici la brèche juste en dessous de nous
nous sommes au courant de ces problèmes
depuis longtemps une collègue me disait
justement que la prairie Souma c'est
l'une des régions inondables les plus
étudiées aux pays et pourtant nous
n'avons pas pu faire mieux
cette région de 3600 hectares a été créé
de toutes pièces par l'humain les 2700
habitants de La Prairie sont à la merci
d'une digue vieillissante de 17 km qui a
pour but d'empêcher la nature de
reprendre ses droits sur ces terres
au début du 20ème siècle les ingénieurs
prédisaient des inondations majeures
tous les centains et bien ces événements
se produisent maintenant tous les 30 ans
ou même tous les 25 ans le défi de
garder les rivières dans leur lit est
d'autant plus complexe puisque ces
terres agricoles chevauchent trois
juridictions fédérales provincial et
municipale
en 2015 ce rapport avait conclu que la
digue de la rivière sous masse n'était
pas assez élevée et qu'elle devait être
renforcée oui nous attend on savait que
la digue de la Souma s'était trop basse
mais le gouvernement municipal n'a pas
assez de ressources financières et si on
voulait améliorer les digues pour
qu'elles respectent les normes
gouvernementales les plus élevées ça
nous coûterait 400 millions de dollars
c'est énorme de ces open nous avons
averti le gouvernement provincial
pendant des années que nous
n'investissons pas assez dans nos
infrastructures depuis des décennies il
faut dire voilà ce qui arrive quand on
ignore les avertissements
dans le sud de la Colombie Britannique
plusieurs communautés sont protégées par
un réseau complexe de 600 km de digue
depuis 20 ans une douzaine d'études ont
sonné l'alarme sur l'état de ces
structures 2015 aucune des évaluer ne
respectait pleinement les exigences
provinciales certaines pourraient céder
advenant une inondation majeure
2016 une inondation majeure dans le sud
de la province deviendrait le désastre
naturel le plus coûteux au pays 2018 la
vérificatrice générale de la
Colombie-Britannique conclut que le
réseau de digue est inadéquat
et six mois avant l'inondation Thompson
si accablant que les fonctionnaires lui
avaient demandé d'atténuer ses propos
nous avons dit que le système de gestion
des risques d'inondation en
Colombie-Britannique était
dysfonctionnelle que la province devait
reprendre le leadership du dossier et
consacré plus d'argent et nous ont
demandé d'enlever ça du rapport c'est un
des moments dont je suis le plus fier
nous l'avons gardé et nous ont ensuite
demandé d'atténuer le langage je ne l'ai
pas fait c'est déchirants vraiment c'est
déchirant Jason est un élu municipal
dans la vallée du fleuve Freezer
je pense que c'était prévisible
[Musique]
on s'est dit ça 15 dernières années j'ai
participé à des études et à des panels
où j'ai soulevé cette inquiétude
le moment viendra où nous devrons tous
rendre des comptes
la province est responsable d’établir
les standards adéquats pour les digues
mais ce sont les municipalités qui
doivent payer la note
c'est absolument ridicule de penser qui
municipalités peuvent payer des millions
de dollars pour améliorer les digues et
c'est injuste de mettre cette
responsabilité sur le dos des
gouvernements locaux
le ministre de la Sécurité publique de
la Colombie Britannique Mike Frances
soutient que la province investit
beaucoup dans les mesures de protection
contre les inondations
[Musique]
nous avons un programme en cours dans le
but est d'assurer que les dégraissent
les normes établies en février 2021 par
exemple nous avons terminé l'évaluation
de la crête des digues pour voir où nous
ensembles
nous avons investi environ 105 millions
de dollars dans nos dix depuis 2 ans
[Musique]
qui disent avoir sonné l'alarme et
demander plus d'appui financiers de la
part de la province
la responsabilité des digues a été
transférée de la province au
gouvernement locaux il y a quelques
années une des leçons que nous retenons
ces inondations c'est qu'il faut
investir davantage dans les digues la
province doit aussi jouer un plus grand
rôle dans le processus
pour thème sunlight c'est à vous arrive
trop tard la province connaissait les
risques ou aurait dû les connaître il y
a eu des rapports à ce sujet depuis des
décennies quand on habite une maison qui
a été inondée c'est extrêmement
frustrant on savait tous que ça s'en
venait
2022 la ville d'habits dévoile un projet
ambitieux pour mieux protéger la prairie
sous-masse à l'avenir
des dizaines de kilomètres de nouvelles
digues quatre nouvelles stations de
pompage pour acheminer l'eau vers le
fleuve freezer ainsi que l'aménagement
d'un terrain qui deviendra un réservoir
en cas de crue excessive
un projet de plusieurs milliards de
dollars de l'argent qui devrait venir en
grande partie de la province
à la veille du premier anniversaire de
l'inondation de novembre 2021 la
province ne s'était toujours pas engagée
à appuyer le projet
j'espère vraiment que ce sera différent
cette fois mais je suis un peu cinique
puisque rien n'a été fait les 20
dernières fois
[Musique]
l'histoire de cela qui s'y transcende
celle des humains dans l'espace il ne
faut pas beaucoup de temps pour que les
choses redeviennent comme avant
ceux qui ont habité la prairie
sous-masse toute leur vie craignent que
ces questions ne soient reléguées aux
oubliettes encore une fois
l'inondation est toujours présente dans
nos esprits mais j'ai d'autres crises
majeures ailleurs et la prairie sous
masse sera oubliée et donc les travaux
nécessaires pour protéger cette région
ne seront plus prioritaires à l'avenir
[Musique]
que dirait son grand-père aujourd'hui
lui qui a aidé à créer la prairie
sous-masse s'il avait été là pour
témoigner d'une autre inondation
dévastatrice
je pense que sachant qu'il a été obligé
de quitter la prairie dans les années 40
justement à cause d'une inondation avec
le recul il dirait qu'on aurait dû faire
les choses autrement et qu'on doit faire
les choses autrement à l'avenir
après l'inondation de 2021 la
municipalité a songé à exproprier
quelques fermes situées près des
rivières mais elle a écarté cette
possibilité
[Musique]
trouve toutefois que le retour des
milieux humides dans la prairie pourrait
être une solution à long terme
si on pouvait renforcer les
infrastructures comme les digues et
créer aussi des zones tampons composées
de milieux humides ça pourrait peut-être
aider il suffirait d'acheter quelques
fermes si elles sont en vente un jour
pour créer ces zones tampons
je sais que nous devons vivre sur ce
territoire c'est l'une des régions les
plus fertiles du Canada et c'est là où
habite tous ces gens nous pouvons faire
mieux
des leçons attirées de cette dépendance
à des régions particulièrement
vulnérables au changement climatique
les problèmes reliés au climat arrive
partout on l'a vu récemment avec les
tempêtes en Ontario et au Québec la
production agricole en Californie est
aussi affectée par les sécheresses
on devrait étudier davantage les
technologies qui nous permettraient de
produire de la nourriture à l'abri des
perturbations
britannique importe l'équivalent de 2
milliards de dollars en légumes feuilles
et en fruits chaque année oui on pouvait
remplacer ça par des produits cultivés
dans des fermes verticales il faut qu'on
soit plus proactif
selon elle la toile de fond du drame de
2021 c'est l'impact que l'activité
humaine a sur le climat
peu importe comment on y arrive il faut
qu'on réduise nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre que ce soit dans nos cils
de vie ou dans nos méthodes de
production agricole il faut qu'on change
nos façons de faire
sinon nos écosystèmes ne survivront pas
c'est aussi simple que ça
la situation est déjà rendue critique à
l'échelle de la planète
les agriculteurs qui ont été les plus
touchés par les inondations ont repris
pour la plupart la routine quotidienne
mais certains comme Philippe Grimm ont
perdu le sentiment de quiétude chez eux
je pense que ça pourrait arriver encore
on a eu trois pluies torrentielles
pourquoi ça n'arriverait pas de nouveau
[Musique]
ici c'est tellement un bel endroit si ça
arrivait de nouveau est-ce que j'y
penserai plus sérieusement probablement
je ne peux pas vivre ça encore deux
trois quatre fois
mais pour voir celui qui a vu la digue
CD à quelques pattes son étable pas
question quitter les Terres où habite sa
famille depuis des générations
on adore cette terre derrière vous se
trouve la tombe de mon père
soit enterré ici
j'ai été élevé ici et je veux y rester
[Musique]